los tratamientos de fertilidad en Países
Bajos están nuevamente bajo el
microscopio jueces le han ordenado a un
hombre poner fin a sus donaciones de
esperma esta persona identificada como
Jonathan M es sospechosa de haber
engendrado entre 550 y 600 hijos desde
que comenzó a donar en el año 2007 mucho
más de las 25 donaciones recomendadas
por las guías clínicas neerlandesas
Susan y Natalie tuvieron un hijo
haciendo uso del esperma de este hombre
hace más de 10 años Aunque siempre
estarán agradecidas con su gesto están
de acuerdo en que las cosas han llegado
demasiado lejos
es realmente ridículo cuántos niños aquí
en los Países Bajos han sido concebidos
con su esperma
más de un centenar de los hijos de
Jonathan nacieron en Países Bajos y
cuando se le prohibió donar en las
clínicas de ese país pasó a hacerlo en
una danesa y también envió su esperma a
direcciones privadas en varios otros
países los jueces dicen que
deliberadamente mal informó a los
futuros padres sobre la cantidad de
hijos que había tenido en el pasado para
la fundación que protege los derechos de
los niños de donantes que llevó el caso
ante los tribunales sus acciones podrían
o pueden ya haber tenido Consecuencias
negativas para los menores
también hay mucha evidencia científica
de que no es saludable para las personas
tener tanta familia puede causar todo
tipo de problemas y eso También incluye
el incesto accidental El caso es el más
reciente escándalo de fertilidad en
sacudir a los Países Bajos en los
últimos años se supo que un ginecólogo
ya fallecido y un médico de una clínica
de fertilidad habían tenido hijos en
secreto con mujeres que pensaban que
estaban recibiendo esperma de donantes
anónimos